this morning Russia is calling up
thousands of reserved troops to fight in
Ukraine and a lot of it is sparking
public anger one monitoring group says
nearly 1400 people in 38 Russian cities
were taken away by police and
anti-government protests yesterday
Deborah patta looks at one small part of
the Russian army collapse in
northeastern Ukraine that led to the
military call up Deborah good morning
good morning Vladimir Putin is a sole
loser he is raising the stakes off the
suffering humiliating losses on the
battlefields of harkiv and we got a rare
look at just how his demoralized troops
performed on the ground
the most fortified Russian base in
occupied harkib collapsed in a matter of
hours it was the breaking point
explained senior Lieutenant taras Perez
of the Bohan Special Forces Brigade
which led the sixth day assault if
Ukrainian Army failed here I think the
whole offensive was in danger
in their line of fire a Russian Base
called masqua after Moscow in the small
village of Nova Jose rizka soldiers
surprised while playing poker this is
where Russian troops set up their
headquarters and you can see look around
they fled in such a hurry it's like a
museum of panic they were in such a rush
to get out of here
military rations gas masks musical
instruments all abandoned as the
commanders were the first to flee
leaving their troops at a nearby Camp
I'm walking down the long line of a
Russian trench dug here this is where
they settled down and had to flee after
owning it for more than six months
it's perfectly preserved a pot of food a
fur coat religious icons even an ancient
typewriter and Ukrainian a forces
effectively attacked Russians not from
the front they've been outflanked and
that is outsmarted and outsmarted they
were fleeting from from here just like
rats
this was supposed to be one of Russia's
elite units many of them paratroopers
the main Putin is now drafting to the
front line a far less experienced some
have never fought in a war
it's a deeply unpopular move back home
sparking Nationwide protests across
Russia that have already seen over 1300
people arrested
as many as three hundred thousand
Russians face the draft those with
medical expertise are being conscripted
with immediate effect and we understand
that call up papers are already being
handed out Gail
all right Deborah Potter in Ukraine we
thank you